[Music]
Kamiyama Senshu Road I
will gladly take over as the leader of the Flower Troupe
[Music] The
5th daughter
, let me know your manners
Daicho,
Sakura Mai
Amamiya My, my arms are healed and I'm beautiful It's
not the power of battle, we'll
restore smiles to our bodies and bodies with our other power
Mochizuki-style ninja Mochizuki scissors From
now on, your flowering  No
matter how much we knit the night star
still has the strength to fight in my chest A lap
pillow on top of my pet is a candy of hope
Fate is already
mine I want to write such a wonderful story too The
sound is  Stronger than the system, with my power, the future is always
[music]